i'm telling you my my face doesn't feel
like my face i can't hear my face right
now i'm with you literally
[Music]
literally hey what's going on everybody
for first week feast i'm shawn evans and
you're watching hot ones it's the show
with hot questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by millie bobby
brown she's an actress and producer you
know best from her role as 11 on the
seven time emmy award-winning global
mega hit show stranger things which
returns for its highly anticipated
fourth season on netflix may 27th millie
bobby brown welcome to the show thank
you very much i'm very excited to be
here well how are you around spicy food
i know that the macadas that you eat on
set from crafty dave you like to hit him
with a little hot sriracha i do i do i
um i was also born in spain so i'm very
familiar with
spicier foods but i i'm quite nervous in
all honesty it's very nerve-wracking
[Music]
can i ask you a question anything you
want if i drink this does it mean i've
given up no no no the you know this we
want it to be like the most comfortable
least comfortable interview if that
makes sense so if you need some
milkshakes why does it already smell
spicy
my nostrils like i have no more hairs
left okay where are we starting at the
uh at the handle over here with the
classic garlic fresno so to your yup
perfect okay
[Music]
do we have a little surprise here to
open things up for wing one we do have a
surprise wow hello noah
i'm glad to be here on the spot giving
us a little assist here for wing one so
is this this is the mild one yep you
lucked out you picked a good time to
come in cheers noah
by the way she was saying that she's so
good at spikes i know i'll find out
today i'm much better with like
well they didn't invite you
but i'm happy to be here
it's not spicy is it
all right now go watch me kill this all
right there we go got the support
hitting the milkshake
right there
so the scene is set for the season four
premiere of stranger things which the
duffer brothers have ominously described
as being the show's game of thrones
season what made shooting this season in
your words the hardest one you've ever
filmed i mean mostly because we filmed
for three years especially with the
amount of filming that we had to do we
were filming in three different places
we were filming in lithuania new mexico
and atlanta and
it was difficult yeah i think that's
yeah
how's that first wing fine doing great
yeah are you ready to move on here to
the next wing yes this right here is the
adobo loco wing sauce a little bit of
like an island vibe with this one
[Music]
nice
really nice
so stranger things isn't the only big
project that you have on the way with
the nola homes 2 coming out soon a
sequel to the acclaimed 2020 film that
you not only started but also produced
between the writing the casting and all
the different aspects of a production
was there anything that you found felt
most natural to you or where you felt
you could make the biggest impact as a
producer producing felt really natural
to me because
i could still create on and off camera
so i could
you know
go on to set and do my thing but also
creatively change the script and go into
editing and it was it was a really cool
position and it actually made me feel
the most comfortable i felt in any set
situation because i felt like i could
i don't know express myself through
fully in my creative
process
from uh gothic victorian dresses to
school uniform disguises pound for pound
what do you think was the best fit in
the whole anola homes project from a
pure costume design perspective um
i love my red dress i think my red dress
is really cool and it symbolizes
you know this masculine kick ass girl
who knows how jiu jitsu but also can cut
see when she needs to i think it's
really sweet
[Music]
is this is this one
it gets a little it gets a little
a little more real here
yep i'm feeling it
was there anything that you found
interesting or amusing about learning
the midwest accent for stranger things i
asked because i'm from illinois oh
really yeah what i will say is that the
duffer brothers who created the show
definitely have that kind of accent
they're not like whiny
but they definitely say y'all and things
like that do you say y'all no i don't
say y'all but like you know also like
milk you know like sometimes i feel like
guests can hear the drawl coming from me
and then they're like well where are you
from and i'm like illinois and then
they're like of course we know why
are there british accents that you think
should get more play in hollywood i love
a liverpudlian accent
anyone from liverpool it sounds i can't
do the accent so don't ask me i won't i
won't but i support the football team
liverpool and they have a really big fa
cup win yeah i know
we're very we're very proud um i love
olivier padley an accent
what is this flavor this is like uh like
a serrano pepper kind of green sauce
[Music]
oh that one's nice you like that one
there we go
i do like that one am i getting
progressively shinier
i hope not yeah you have the nice hot
ones glow that we like to see at this
point in the show so when we had rob
lowe on the show he described eating on
camera as being one of the most
difficult actor tricks of all time what
are the forces at play that makes
shooting a scene in which your character
is wolfing down diner food or eggo
waffles by the dozen what makes those
scenes for an actor so much more
difficult than an audience may realize
because you're doing it for 12 hours so
usually what you do is you just get a
little bucket beside you and you can
just
spit into it after every take or
sometimes during the take but most of
the time i just go
and then just pretend i'm eating which
always kind of works um but other than
that yeah you just start to feel really
nauseous it's horrible and whatever you
choose to eat on that plate
you're eating for 12 hours so usually i
always choose like a salad or a fruit
it works
and then on the topic we talked about
one of your favorite snacks the macad
what is a mccod and can you talk me
through how to make one if i wanted to
try it for myself oh yes okay so what we
do is we get a piece of lettuce and we
get cut up
ham
peppers and then we get sriracha and we
cover the whole kind of sandwich in it
and then they usually make me like six
of them and that is what keeps me going
on set it's the best ever with no you
will buy my cards fueled yeah and and i
think it's the last name of the guy who
makes it that's why we call it my card
crafty dave crafty day shout out to
crafty dave all right you are doing so
good by the way thank you we are to the
halfway point are you ready to move on
here to number five yeah
so this is the seventh reaper here at
five
[Music]
that one's also nice
it's nice i like it there we go i'm
feeling pretty good god i thought this
would be a lot worse than i thought well
do you start to feel it do you start to
feel it soon it does get a little
crazier in the back half but you are
crushing this okay good absolutely
crushing good i'm not saying i'm not
feeling it but it's not making me want
to cry like tom holland
is that bad
okay good we haven't even hit the
milkshakes yet i know should can we sure
sure i'm just wanting to try it
oh this is good where did we get this
from
five guys guys also why do five guys not
put their chips in a thing they always
just put it in the bag don't they oh
right right yeah just uh the fries just
hanging loose in the loosen the bag so
why are there peanuts in there like
who eats peanuts anyways
all right all right millie we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that graham where we do a deep
dive on our guest instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
context so we'll pull the picture up
over here on the monitor you just tell
us the bigger story
what was the highlight of the afternoon
you spent ripping laps with lewis
hamilton at the circuit of america uh i
got to do a hot lap with him
oh little tease yeah
and we got to
go around the
racetrack and it was amazing it was a
really cool experience very terrifying
almost as terrifying as this one but it
was really cool and this moment was when
we were about to get in the car
so you see i'm a bit nervous yeah yeah
but then just like this show you get
down in the seat and then you just own
it right you've got to you've got to no
one's taking me down
all right up next for you
besides godzilla actually being a tennis
ball you're delivering lines to what
blew your mind most about the technical
wizardry that goes into making a kaiju
blockbuster it's insane it's insane it
also takes longer to
to put godzilla in there than to
actually film it
they are so unbelievably talented in
that field that they can you know it was
he was literally a tennis thought i
remember my neck hurting because i was
always looking up in that film
oh
my god i'm nervous now you're telling me
that i've got four more left
i just didn't get enough there you go i
don't want anyone to think i've wimped
out
so one of the unique elements of
stranger things is it seems like you and
your castmates have been given a deal of
creative input even from a young age is
there an example of an 11 character
trait or stranger things plot point that
you're proudest to have fought for or
put your fingerprints on in some way
yeah i think this season that i i feel
that the most like with
the bullying aspect of what eleven's
going through i feel really proud to
represent that kind of storyline because
that's a very real thing people do deal
with that um in school and i think
you know it's a hard thing to film for
sure especially from someone who has
gone through bullying but yeah i just
feel
i feel really proud to have done that
how would you grade hollywood's ability
to harness young people's creativity
these days because people have gone from
being you know just actors to now with
some being like show runners and
executive producers at younger and
younger ages
yeah i mean we're getting there we are
getting there i think that we have
amazing corporations say like netflix
and legendary who have given me
opportunities to produce and to be part
of my projects collaboratively um not
only as a young person but a young girl
i think those types of things are
getting the ball rolling and pushing
society to trust
gen z and all that we have to offer
[Music]
it's not really psyching me out
do you know what it feels like have you
ever gotten a ct scan
i have
actually and they put the dye in you
yeah yeah that's what it feels like your
body just kind of gets all warm
it's fun
so one of the hallmarks of stranger
things is 80s nostalgia which is given
life through this meticulous commitment
to period pieces
to period details what's the first thing
though you seem to be choking up a bit
here listen i haven't just beat you on
your own show haven't you you listen it
happens every once in a while i'm but a
a humble chicken wing talk show host you
know i'm just out here trying my best
we appreciate that
what's the first thing that comes to
mind when you think about the obsessive
level of detail that went into a set
piece to keep it authentic to the period
ooh
we used a lot of helicopters in our show
we have to be like
we have to get a helicopter that's
basically from the 80s i think that's
insane that also goes up in the sky do
you know what i mean right they can
still do it yeah they can still do it or
they have to paint it to absolutely
replicate an htc's helicopter i think
that's very impressive to me the mall to
me was impressive as
i mean that that attention to detail the
fact that it wasn't called gap and it
was called the gap like certain things
like that i'm like wow that's just it's
really cool
all the clothes were from the 80s they
all had tags on it from the 80s like it
was all very very nostalgic for my
family my parents
and not really for me at all but it was
really cool to be in it felt like you
were really in it and then i understand
that you know part of the requisite
homework was watching movies like the
goonies or poltergeist or stand by me
yeah did you walk away from that
experience with uh film in particular
that meant the most to you i love et et
reminds me of 11 a lot because you know
et
is this kind of
thing that's come down from a different
planet it kind of feels like 11's come
down from this different planet doesn't
know anyone and trusts elliott and i
think 11 trusts mike and it's quite a
nice you know that's quite a nice
resemblance
all right so this next one
is the bomb beyond insanity
a sauce
that's reputation precedes it just a
little bit okay
all right and then this is this is one
that's like a prank but you're crushing
me like a prank
this one is just worse there's just
something about this one
[Music]
hello
that's not even normal no nothing about
it nothing about it
that like made me want to stop breathing
just hit that milkshake i did so [ __ ]
well
you're still doing well you're still
crushing it oh no you're still doing
good now
just ask me a question okay sure sure
you know it's not every day
that we have a hot ones guests who have
their very own eyewear line what to you
is like fundamental or key when pulling
out a perfect pair of spectacles or
shades
what one did tom holland cry at
at this one this one
i just need an ice cube in my mouth yeah
yeah um
well i really like
cat eye
sunglasses
it's on my gums yeah yeah
tongue lips my hair is falling out
[Laughter]
i really
[Music]
like cat eye
shapes
well if you'll humor me what i want to
do is show you some pictures from iconic
celebrity sunglass moments from the past
i'm just curious how they hit your
expert eye you know the things that are
working for you the things that don't
work for you and we'll start with elton
john why did you do this to me i'm only
18.
[Music]
only small
do you have any thoughts on these shades
from elton john's yeah they're so like
they're so great
i love them
what about this thumbs up or thumbs way
up on missy elliott's
crystal mask look
i love them they're great
i love that
all right
next up next why it's like not getting
better though i know i know it's just
gonna grow a little bit
do you have a preference between the
risky business i don't like neither they
don't look nice
i don't like those ones
they don't suit me there we go there we
go one more for you before we go last
but not least your thoughts on lady gaga
the 2019 met gala yep it was a lovely
look
by her i don't think i can do more
is that one worse
don't try and talk me through this tell
me right now is the is that
is that nice one bad
it's not worse than the last one is it
gonna make what i'm feeling right now
though the the after effect of that one
you led me into that if i ever trust you
again
[Music]
no it's already burning my nose
whoa
what do you mean whoa no i just i like
this i just like the determination
i want to do this you guys i'm telling
you my my face doesn't feel like my face
i can't hear my face right now i'm with
you literally
literally oh my god
we got it we got it
so i know that you have a spiritual
connection with whales one's saying that
they symbolize you as a person to quote
they're loud and they're queens of the
sea is there a whale fun fact or a
quality that you see in whales that you
see most in yourself um humpback whales
humpback whales float and eat all day
girls and they all like to be girls
that one isn't good i i yeah i know i
know do you want some ice cubes no yes
here we go look it
you want it we got it thank you ma'am
there we go
there we go
from your unique perspective godzilla
destructive and rampaging sea monster or
misunderstood environmental activist a
misunderstood environmental activist
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you don't have to if you don't want to
no
why are you doing it you don't have to
prove anything you're great
you're great you're doing great yeah you
know what you're right i don't have to
prove anything no you don't you know i
think i'm so mechanical and like just
going through this all the time that i
don't stop to think about like yourself
right there's no need
for me to like
spike the ball in the end zone or
whatever no you don't all right well
you're right
i'm gonna pop you're doing great
you're doing great tell me about your
life
from illinois
75 years ago
no kids no kids you don't want kids
all right now i'm mentally and
emotionally younger than you
[Music]
i know if i throw up
will you be there for me i'm i'm here
for you always we're forever bonded all
right we will
we're forever bothered i just need to
swallow it okay yep
you got it
you got it
and the good news here
we're done i know i don't really talk
anymore i don't need you to talk yeah
stranger things executive producer and
director sean levy who once said that
you're able to convey more without a
word than many actors convey with
monologues so to close things out i'll
point to a hot sauce you just react to
what it was like to eat that hot sauce
okay purely in a facial expression sure
the one that we just ate the last ab
that
oh how about this one that you really
liked uh lois caliente's verde
and then how about the one that uh
almost made you write me off forever to
bomb beyond insanity
[Music]
that's what my insides were doing
not a dry eye in the house and look at
you millie bobby brown taking on the
wings of death and living to tell the
tale and now there's nothing left to do
but roll out the red carpet for you this
camera this camera this camera let the
people know what you have going on in
your life
guys
my my lips
at least i'm gonna have like kylie
jenner
all right i'm just gonna live with it
guys what stranger things season four
[Music]
it just feels like everything needs to
be talked a lot slower yeah we just
gotta you know we gotta take these times
yeah chill it out a little bit right
well you just promo the show
stranger things uh may 27th season four
the show must be good because she's here
eating scorching hot chicken wings thank
you so much for having me here
yeah
that's the hot ones experience
i had so
i got
much fun
yeah yeah come on in come on in you did
it you did so good
much
hey what's going on hot ones fans thank
you so much for watching today's video
the season 18 sauces they're here and
you know what that means dom box me
so is the big box the season 18 hot ones
box is now available at heatness.com
that's heatness.com to get your hands
and all of the season 18 sauces
delivered straight to your door in one
convenient box don't forget to be
careful around the eyes